جدل يواكب موسم سينما العيد في مصر رحيل
محمد قنوع سعدنا مجرد خارج السجن هل سيغير
تحت الوصايه القانون وماذا عن جزء ثاني من
جعفر العمده اليكم الابرز في اسبوع
[موسيقى]
امضى الفنان المغربي سعد المجرد عطله
العيد بين احضان عائلته في فرنسا وذلك
بعدما حصل على اطلاق سراح مؤقت بينما
ينتظر الفرج في الاستئناف بحسب ما اعلن في
تدوينه نشرها عبر حساباته الرسميه على
مواقع التواصل متوجها بالشكر لكل من سانده
في محنته كما اعلن رسميا عن طرح كليب جديد
مطلع ايار مايو المقبل وحكم على المجرد
بالسجن لمده 6 سنوات بتهمه الاغتصاب
والاعتداء على شابه فرنسيه في غرفه فندق
باريس في اكتوبر تشرين الاول عام 2016
ونبقى في اجواء العيد والجدل الذي واكب
عرض افلام الموسم السينمائي في مصر فقبل
عرض فيلم هارلي من بطوله محمد رمضان اصدرت
نقابه المهن السينمائيه بيانا اعلنت فيه
التاكد من صحه واقعه استمرار فريق الفيلم
في التصوير لمده 54 ساعه متواصله وبناء
عليه تم توجيه اللوم الشديد للشركه
المنتجه كما انتقدت ايمان حميده ابنه
ومدير اعمال الفنان محمود حميده خلال
الشركه المنتجه بشروط العقد مع النجم
المصري فيما يتعلق بطريقه كتابه اسمه على
التتر معتبره ذلك احسن مثال على عدم
الاحترام او التقدير او حتى المهنيه او
عدم احترام الحقوق الادبيه والمعنويه وعدم
الالتزام بالعقود التي هي شريعه
المتعاقدين وذلك بحسب تدوينه لايمان عبر
صفحتها على فيسبوك نشرت فيها صوره للعقد
ورغم صدور قرار بمنع عرض فيلم رمسيس باريس
من المحكمه الاقتصاديه بالقاهره بحسب
المستشار القانونيه سرقنطوش عرض الفيلم
الذي تتصدر بطولته ويفاء وهبي في مصر لو
قالت لك اخبارين من لوفر ان في اثار مصريه
اتسرقت مش عايزك تتخضي عشان
وفي نافذه اخيره على اصداء موسم دراما
رمضان 2023 تشير اراء النقاد والمتابعين
على منصات التواصل الى الجماهيريه الكبيره
التي حققها مسلسل جعفر العمده في مصر
وخلال اطلالته الاعلاميه في برنامج صاحبه
السعاده نفا محمد رمضان
نيه صناع العمل انتاج جزء ثاني منه رغم
النجاح الكبير ورغبه الشركه المنتجه كما
احتفل المتابعون بتكامل ووضوح رساله مسلسل
تحت الوصايه الذي استطاع ان يحبس انفاس
المشاهدين حتى اخر لحظه وسط اشاده كبيره
بصناع العمل وابطاله وعلى راسهم النجمه
المصريه منى زكي التي توجهت بالشكر عبر
حساباتها الرسميه على مواقع التواصل لكل
من ساهم بانجازه متمنيه ان يكون نقطه
بدايه لاعاده النظر في قوانين الوصايه
واعطاء الامهات الحق في اولادهم النجمه
هاله صدقي حققت نجاحا لافتا ايضا في موسم
العرض الرمضاني حيث حظيت شخصيه صفصف او
الملكه وصيفه بجماهيريه كبيره على منصات
التواصل
بينما حجزت دنيا سمير غانم مساحه خاصه على
مستوى الاداه وشكل الفني في مسلسل جت
سليمه الذي حقق نجاحا كبيرا في النصف
الثاني من رمضان واحتفى محبو النجم
المصريه بظهور ابنتها كايلا في احد
المشاهد المشتركه بينهما في المسلسل
واخيرا فارق الفنان السوري محمد قنوع
الحياه عن عمري 49 عاما اثر تعرضه لازمه
قلبيه وهز نبا رحيله الوسط الفني في سوريا
وشهد تشيعه الى مثواه الاخير في دمشق
حضورا شعبيا وفنيا كبيرا وكان من اخر
ادواره المميزه التي قدمها في موسم دراما
رمضان 2023 شخصيه شومان التي جسدها في
مسلسل العربجي